ich habe mich noch nie so über ein Paket
gefreut wie heute wir packen das jetzt
zusammen aus das ist meine Wurzelwerk
Saatgut Box meine allererste und wow ich
habe mich schon so oft über die
Saatgutindustrie geärgert und ich habe
schon so lange den Traum in mir mein
eigenes samenfestes biologisches Saatgut
von richtig robustensorten teilweise
sehr alten und seltenen Sorten
anzubieten jetzt habe ich es zum
allerersten Mal in meinen Händen schauen
wir mal rein ich bin viel zu aufgeregt
das ist nur ein Päckchen Marie ich will
es gar nicht zerschneiden
und wisst ihr das ist
was ich mir vorgestellt habe genau
dieses Gefühl gerade ich weiß nicht ob
wir das sehen aber hier wird man als
erstes von einer Karte begrüßt auf der
Karte steht zu sehen wie aus einer
Handvoll Samen ein ganzer Garten wächst
ist eines der größten Wunder der Welt
jetzt ist nicht einfach nur eine
saatgutbestellung das ist so als würde
man dreimal im Jahr Weihnachten feiern
wir wollen dass Ihr Euch richtig freuen
über die Sachen die in der Box sind und
dass jedes Mal auch eine kleine
Überraschung mit drin ist und dann kommt
ein Brief von mir für euch ihr bekommt
also jedes Mal auch kleine Tipps mit auf
den Weg ein bisschen Motivation mit auf
den Weg und ähm Hintergrund zu den
Sorten die wir ausgewählt haben und dann
geht's an aufpacken also ich muss euch
das jetzt zeigen
seht ihr das es gibt mir gerade
irgendwie weiß ich weiß nicht ob ihr das
kennt aber wenn ich bei dem kleinen
Geschäft was bestelle und die das dann
so liebevoll einpacken dann ich weiß
nicht es macht einfach glücklich oha
oha Leute
da sind unsere Tütchen
und nicht mehr da
okay ich habe sie schon mal gesehen in
echt die Türchen aber die sind einfach
so unfassbar schön
hier haben wir noch die buschbohne die
ist
größeren und deswegen hat die das
Tütchen ein anderes Format
oh mein Gott
ich bin auch so froh dass wir die
Illustratoren gefunden haben diese
unglaublich schöne
Zeichnungen von den Gemüsepflanzen
gemacht hat
schaut mal
wow
meine allerliebste Sorte ist hier
gewesen
ah ich hoffe dass ihr euch genauso
darüber freut wie ich gerade ich meine
für mich ist es noch mal was anderes ne
ich glaube niemand von euch wird
wirklich Tränen in den Augen haben wenn
er das auspackt das wäre ein bisschen zu
viel verlangt aber hier ist noch was
drin in der Box ich möchte das dass ihr
richtig von den Socken seid wenn ihr das
auspackt und deswegen haben wir keine
Kosten und Mühen gescheut und jeder Box
ein Wurzelwerk die kirscht dabei gelegt
ich glaube ich muss mal mein Gesicht zu
halten damit er das fokussiert das sind
die tierstäbe die aus deutschen Holz im
Erzgebirge hergestellt werden von der
kleinen Werkstatt den willst nicht bei
uns im Shop geben den bekommt ihr wenn
ihr eure erste Box bestellt für alle die
sich Wissen ein pikierstab nimmt man um
Jungpflanzen die man ausgewählt hat in
der Jungpflanzen Anzucht aus der Erde
rauszuheben und dann um zu pflanzen ich
habe dafür schon alles Mögliche
verwendet von Löffeln über Eisstäbchen
über was weiß ich ich glaube sogar
ich kann nicht glauben dass wir jetzt an
dem Punkt sind dass wir sowas machen
ich hoffe ihr freut euch
aber was ist jetzt ein Saatgut enthalten
wir haben einmal die buschbohne purple
TP und es sind alles Sorten die sich bei
uns bewährt haben und die ich auch schon
oft in meinen Videos erwähnt habe die in
meinen pflanzplänen vorkommen das ist
also genau ein Guss mit dem ganzen
Wurzelwerk Universum und die purple Pipi
ist eine lilane buschbohne die also lila
farbene Hülsen bildet die wunderschön
sind es ist eine zarte ursprünglich
schmeckt super lecker leider ist es so
wenn man die Bohnen dann in die Pfanne
gibt dass sie am Ende grün werden aber
das ist bei allen Lieder Bohnen so es
gibt soweit ich weiß keine lila wohne
bei der das nicht passiert
Träne Taler die Karotte das ist eine
karottensorte die sehr gut jetzt zur
Jahreszeit passt früher im Jahr werde
ich noch eine andere Sorte aber diese
Box geht ja Anfang April an euch raus
manche Leute bestellen die vielleicht
auch erst Mitte April bekommen die ein
bisschen später und wir achten bei der
Zusammenstellung der Boxen darauf dass
das natürlich immer zur Jahreszeit passt
und dass sie auch nicht so einen Stress
bekommt wenn die Box anfangen april bei
euch auf der Fußmatte liegt dass ihr
dann in den nächsten zwei Wochen alles
ausgesät haben ist hier zum Beispiel
habt ihr bis Ende Juni Zeit um diese
Karotte zu sehen ihr könnt aber
natürlich auch direkt loslegen wenn ihr
die Box bekommt dann haben wir hier den
Wirsing das ist ein Wintergemüse viele
denken dass man Wintergemüse erst im
Winter aussieht aber dann haben die ja
gar keine Chance noch richtig groß zu
werden und deswegen ist jetzt die Zeit
um das zu machen und deswegen ist der
wer singt diesmal mit in der Box
gelandet es sind z.B keine Tomaten dabei
in dieser Box weil das jetzt schon
relativ spät wäre die Tomaten kommen
dann mit der übernächsten Box also wir
haben eine Box die wir jetzt Anfang
April versenden dann eine Anfang
September für die ganzen Herbst Ausatmen
da kann man auch noch jede Menge machen
kurz vor dem Winter und dann haben wir
eine Box die geht Ende Dezember raus
damit ihr im neuen Jahr gleich startklar
seid und eure Samen parat haben
vielleicht auch damit wir noch kleines
Weihnachtsgeschenk beilegen kann ja
haben wir den Mangold das ist die Sorte
Feuer eine sehr schöne rote Sorte bei
Mangold könnt ihr übrigens auch immer
wieder ernten also wenn ihr den jetzt
ausseht und einfach immer nur einzelne
Stangen abschneidet aber das Herz der
Pflanze intakt lasst dann bildet die
Pflanze immer wieder neue Blätter und
ihr müsst nicht ständig neue nachsehen
dann haben wir hier die Zucchini Coco
Zelle von Tripolis auch einer meiner
absoluten Lieblingssorten die ist so
wunderschön
gestreifte Früchte also die haben so
eine weiße Marmorierung ist eine sehr
ertragreiche Sorte eine sehr robuste
Sorte wir hatten so ein bisschen
gefleckte Blätter manche Leute denken
das wäre Mehltau aber das ist nicht so
gibt einfach so in dieser Blätter haben
dann haben wir hier den Winterlauf auch
dafür ist es jetzt Zeit dass sie den
aussieht das ist die Sorte blau grüner
Winter Husky also auch eine Sorte die
ich ja quasi jedes Jahr bei mir im
gartenbaue der Kohlrabi ist der Star
beim Kohlrabi gibt es sehr schöne lila
Farben und das ist eine die auch noch
richtig gut schmeckt also ich finde das
aussehen darf nie auf Kosten des
Geschmacks gehen aber wenn man bunte
Sorten nehmen kann dann bitte her damit
dann haben wir hier einen sehr sehr
schönen Salat der heißt Summertime ist
auch genau auf die Jahreszeit jetzt
abgestimmt damit ihr auch in den
Sommermonaten richtig schöne Salat haben
können vielleicht für Grillabend und so
weiter ich bin ja eher der Typ der jeden
Quadratzentimeter im Garten für Sachen
nutzt die man essen kann aber
Blumen im Garten ohne Blumen ist auch
traurig ne deswegen sind ab und zu auch
Blumen in unseren Boxen dabei z.B hier
diese Kapuzinerkresse das ist der
perfekte Kompromiss falls ihr auch so
wie ich weil man die nämlich auch essen
kann also man kann sowohl die Blüten als
auch die Früchte die kleinen Samen die
die später bilden Essen die Blüten kann
man in den Salat geben auch die Blätter
kann man essen die haben so eine richtig
schöne Würze die Früchte die sich aus
dem Blüten bilden also die kleinen Samen
sind wenn sie unreif sind die perfekten
also man kann die dann einfach einlegen
und so kann man aus dem eigenen Garten
haben und haben wir noch einmal Kräuter
mit dabei weil Kräuter natürlich auch in
keinem Garten fehlen dürfen und das ist
der Jill das ist auch so so ein
Allrounder oder und der wächst auch
richtig schnell passt gut zu Jahreszeit
wir haben ja auf den Rückseiten der
Tütchen auch alle möglichen Angaben die
ihr braucht für die Aussaat z.B die
auswahlzeit Punkte bei manchen sollten
die man im Haus vorzieht sind dann auch
noch ist noch die Jungpflanzen Anzug im
Haus und die Pflanzung nach draußen
angegeben die Pflanzabstände wie sonnig
das Gemüse erstmal wie viel Wasserbedarf
ist halt wir haben auch für alle die auf
dem balkongärtnern hier drüben immer
eine Angabe wie groß der Topf sein
sollte die guten Mischkultur Partner
Wasser mir doch alles drauf welche
Pflanzenfamilie ist es wie man die
Fruchtfolge einhalten soll hier ist noch
unser Bio Siegel und dann haben wir hier
immer noch einen kompletten Anbau
Steckbrief verlinkt den ihr dann online
einsehen kann wenn ihr noch mehr Infos
zu den jeweiligen Pflanzen also im
eigentlich bringt sich die Saatgut
Rückseite schon alles mit was man
braucht um am Ende dann auch einen
fetten Ernte kommt mit nach Hause zu
bringen eine Frage die auch oft kam war
für welche Gartengröße ist denn die
Saatgut Box ausgelegt wir haben in jedem
Tütchen so viel drin dass man einen
großen Garten damit bestellen kann aber
bei den allermeisten Gemüsearten kann
man seit gut ja mehrere Jahre
aufbewahren so dass man selbst wenn man
nur drei vier Beete hat oder auch nur
ein Bild das ist gut ja jedes Jahr
wieder verwenden kann ich verwende z.B
auch regelmäßig vier Jahre altes
Karotten seit gut das funktioniert
solange man das trocken dunkel und kühl
lagert es gibt nur so ein paar Ausnahmen
wie z.B die Pastinake und der Sellerie
die sehr kurz nur keins sind wo man dann
jedes Jahr oder jedes zweite Jahr neues
hat gut kaufen müsste aber die haben wir
jetzt in unseren Boxen zumindest dieses
Jahr nicht eingeplant und wenn das mal
der Fall ist dann sind das nur einzelne
Gemüsearten aber im Normalfall könnt ihr
dann einfach wenn ihr Samen überhaupt
habe ich eigentlich auch jedes Jahr bei
jedem
könnt ihr die einfach im nächsten Jahr
wieder verwenden oder an Freunde
weitergeben mit anderen Leuten tauschen
kleine tauschpartys machen und so ist es
eben möglich dass die Box für alle
gartengrößen geeignet ist egal ob man
den kleinen oder einen riesengroßen
Garten hat vor allem habe ich so Lust
darauf zu sehen wie diese Samen jetzt
bei euch im Garten wachsen also dieser
Spruch hier ne den meine ich tote Ernst
ich schicke euch eine Handvoll Samen das
wird euer zukünftiger Garten was eine
unglaubliche Vorstellung also wenn ihr
Lust habt wenn ihr euch eine Saatgut Box
holen wollt könnt ihr entweder unser Abo
auswählen da bekommt ihr dreimal im Jahr
unsere Boxen zugeschickt im April im
September und dann Ende Dezember fürs
neue Jahr und immer auch eine kleine
Überraschung mit dabei wir wollen dass
das ein richtig schönes Erlebnis für
euch wird und wenn ihr erstmal nur eine
Box wollt dann könnt ihr auch unsere
schnupperbox auswählen auf der Seite ich
verlinke die euch da oben und unten im
obersten angepinnten Kommentar damit ihr
euch anmelden könnt wir haben nur eine
begrenzte Zahl von Boxen es sind noch
welche da aber kann nicht sagen wie
lange und ja klappt sie euch und dann
haben wir auf der Unterseite noch ein
paar Fakten zu unserem Gras Karton weil
ich mir gedacht habe Versandhandel ist
eigentlich nicht so beweglich nachhaltig
und was können wir machen damit wir euch
trotzdem erreichen bei unsere Zuschauer
ja überall in Deutschland verteilt sind
viele auch in Österreich und der Schweiz
teilweise auch Leute in Frankreich oder
in Schweden und deswegen haben wir nach
Lösungen gesucht wie wir z.B die
Verpackung möglichst nachhaltig
gestalten wie wir den Versand möglichst
nachhaltig gestalten und hier haben wir
zum Beispiel graskarton genommen der ist
aus 35% heimischen Gas und das ist
recyceltes Altpapier und dadurch
verbraucht das Ganze eben viel weniger
Wasser Energie und Ressourcen Dankeschön
an alle die meinen Kanal mein Block und
so weiter so unterstützt haben dass es
uns möglich ist sowas zu machen ich
hoffe so sehr dass euch das genauso
freut mich es gerade gefreut hat die Box
auszupacken
das ist gerade wirklich ein sehr großer
Moment für mich ich habe schon wieder
Tränen in den Augen ich habe schon
wieder eine sehr belegte Stimme weil
mir das so viel bedeutet dass ich all
das machen darf was ich jeden Tag mache
dass ich so viele Leute inspirieren darf
rauszugehen und loszuwerden weil das
braucht die Welt und
ja danke schön danke selbst wenn ihr
diese Box nicht bestellt es müsst ihr
nicht ich will
das nur bestellt wenn ihr es auch
wirklich in eurem Garten nutzen wollt
und da Freude daran habt dass ich das
machen darf wenn ich das meinem ich vor
zehn Jahren erzähle ich mir im Leben
nicht geglaubt also danke
macht's gut